The doll in M3GAN has a lot of
similarities to Chucky from the
Child's Play movies. So was M3GAN created with
multiple animatronics like her red-haired
predecessor? The answer may surprise you.
Little girls are surely regretting asking
for a doll for Christmas if they've seen
the trailers for the upcoming sci-fi horror
film M3GAN. Likewise, any adults who have a
doll collection might be starting to grow
wary of them. But, at the end of the day,
they're just dolls, right? They couldn't
possibly be that scary. Universal Pictures
has been fueling suspense with their movie's
second trailer which dropped on December 8,
2022. The new trailer raised the stakes
considerably; the dancing M3GAN means business,
which may make it impossible for people to
ever look at dolls the same way ever again.
"You should probably run."
M3GAN follows the story of Gemma, who has
recently taken in her niece Cady after Cady's
parents perish in a car accident. Unsure of how
to care for her niece, or for children in general,
Gemma is able to compensate. As a roboticist,
Gemma develops a Model 3 Generative Android,
M3GAN for short, to provide friendly company for
her bereaved niece. Cady forms a deep attachment
with M3GAN, and this attachment goes both
ways — with dark and deadly consequences.
This isn't the first time audiences have seen a
film starring a deadly doll with a penchant for
murder. Child's Play, featuring the red-haired
Good-Guy Chucky doll and released in 1988,
paved the way with a long line of movies,
sequels, and a TV show that started in 2021.
"I'm new and improved."
There's also Annabelle as part of The Conjuring
universe, who just makes the skin crawl
despite more or less sitting around completely
motionless. Meanwhile, M3GAN has something extra
that makes her feel that much scarier than her
contemporaries. The most disturbing thing about
her of all? No one is allowed to know how she was
made and brought to life on the silver screen.
According to an interview with Total Film,
director Gerard Johnstone has sworn himself
and the entire crew involved to secrecy regarding
how they pulled off bringing M3GAN to life. While
actor Jenna Davis is credited as M3GAN on the
production's cast list via IMDB, she only receives
voice credit, meaning that there's a whole lot
more to the sinister cinematic android that
we've been told. When asked if Cady actress Violet
McGraw bonded with M3GAN on set, Johnstone shared,
There's something comforting about knowing
how things were done off-screen. For one,
those who were terrified of Chucky
from Child's Play would do well to
know that the doll was created with multiple
animatronics by technician Kevin Yagher,
as explained by "The Making of Child's Play."
Knowing the creators were in charge of Chucky's
movements the whole time via remote control
would certainly comfort a scared moviegoer.
In order to make M3GAN truly terrifying,
what could be better than hiding how they
pulled it off? It's been more than 30
years since Child's Play was released,
and technology has advanced considerably since
then. As a result, Johnstone had multiple
options to pull this sinister robot-doll
protector to life. Instead of a puppet,
they could use a real actor with CGI,
adopt animatronics, or perhaps a mix.
In this regard, Johnstone vaguely and — be it on
purpose or not — ominously said that they
employed a "multi-tiered approach," which
is hopefully enough to keep those
with doll phobias awake at night.